speaking of intuition that was actually
my next question so it's working very
well because you had said somewhere else
that you wanted to stay out of the way
of your own film and let the amino
dictate sort of how it was going to be
how do you think we as filmmakers get in
the way of our work I found that
fascinating when you said that I think
when we come up with a plan and stick to
it no matter how much the university is
kind of going no you should go this way
I think when you get dead set like it
has to be this way rather than just kind
of going with the flow and I for me it
was really about just setting that
intention of I want this to be the
Caminos film I want this to be the
highest and greatest thing that it can
be and I want it to be if the Camino was
a person and could make the film that's
what I want and so I might have my my
things I mean personally if if it was
just me and my film we would have had
like six sections on snoring but you
know thank God for editors but I also
realized it like no that's that's that
was just my issue it's not everybody's
issue I think that's the biggest thing
is is setting an intention more than
anything and not necessarily worrying
about how it has to fulfill itself but
just saying this is my intention and I'm
going to trust that it's going to come
out that way and I also did what's
called visioning it's a process one of
my spiritual teachers is Reverend
Michael Beckwith and I was trained as a
practitioner at agape and he has this
thing called visioning which is sort of
going into a meditative state and sort
of letting things come to you so the
idea being and I feel like this that
it's it's really kind of coming through
me not rather just rather than originate
originating with me it's coming kind of
through rather than just starting here
and coming out any advice to fellow
filmmakers on when they find themselves
getting in their way or being too
attached to the results of something
with your filming were there other
instances aside from the story which I
thought was very funny that the few that
you did have in there was right but um
where you found you know what I need to
get out of the way of this film I'm
coming in too much I'm a big proponent
of meditation I think quieting our minds
and just calming the mind and for me
it's it's totally a practice I would not
say I am totally successful quieting my
mind by no means but it is the practice
of doing that and of sitting every day
so that that is what really works for me
and on the shoot many times I I had two
people on the on the crew that were very
solid meditators they also had a daily
practice and occasionally when I just
felt really just completely at odds with
everything I would grab one of them and
say come meditate with me and even just
10 minutes made a really big difference
and Annie also was a really big support
for me on the shoot she because she's
from agape we did what's called
spiritual mind treatment and she would
really kind of try and hold me in in
consciousness there's a bunch of
terminology that we use but she was
really very helpful as well and let me
think I think the other thing that that
from my spiritual work that I've really
learned to lean into is that what looks
like an obstacle or what looks like
really horrible news can be great news
and that was one of those things that
you know each time something came up
like I had this really big insight about
I was so frustrated at how long it was
taking me to raise the money to finish
the film and it was so hard and I you
know the way shot after us and they came
out years before and I was so frustrated
you know just struggling with trying to
get the money and it was we were in
Portland for 11 weeks for our first run
and it
after coming back from one of those qas
I was on there I was walking down to my
house and it just dawned on me what was
so challenging in that moment has been
my biggest blessing because because the
way came out two years before it paved
the way for us and it made our way so
much easier and so there was really a
blessing in it and the more you can lean
into that and go okay I'm really unhappy
with this situation and I'm sure there's
something good coming from this and just
keep yourself in that and and be open to
the what good that could what good be
could be happening that you're not aware
of just yet and even to your life in
2007 as probably difficult as it was yes
it shook things up but then you went on
the Camino and look what's happened as a
result exactly same type of thing and
that seemed to be a theme yeah and the
other thing I wanted to mention that as
I personally do a lot of work on myself
and I think that's very important I work
with a spiritual practitioner on a very
consistent basis and that was a big part
of the film because my stuff was getting
was coming up a lot of people in the
crew a lot of people kind of connected
to the film their stuff is coming up and
without having someone that I was
consistently working with to go this is
coming up you know what how am I
contributing to this and how do i need
to shift and where can i grow and how
can i be more of who i really want to be
and and i also work with a therapist on
you know he he's kind of I call him now
and then when things come up I'm just a
really big proponent of getting help of
you know I don't think we're here on
this planet meant to try and figure
everything out by ourselves I really
think that give and take and having
somebody outside yourself and especially
when it's somebody professional because
it's a lot of pressure I think to put on
our friends lie
I'm going through this really hard time
help me and not only that they're not
trained and but the more we can kind of
look at ourselves and look at what's
happening on my side of the street like
you may be doing what what's going on
over here but I have the opportunity to
look at it differently to reframe it to
to really step into Who I am instead of
getting sucked into just a reaction
you